tutti noi apriamo almeno una porta la
nostra giornata
Io ne ho per te tre che hanno cambiato
la mia vita professionale e quella di
molte altre persone
sono un medico ma un medico particolare
solo un anatomopatologo
io non curo i pazienti a loro a loro
letto Io studio le malattie e loro
effetti sugli organi
le studio direttamente e studio al
microscopio
e fai fotopsie
Mi porterò con me
indietro nel tempo un anno e mezzo Siamo
marzo 2020 piena pandemia Bergamo
probabilmente è una delle città più
martoriate del mondo e l'ospedale Papa
Giovanni XXIII è l'ospedale covid-19 più
grosso d'Europa
vorrei che pensate per un attimo a
quando nella vostra vita è capitato di
dover fare qualcosa
controvoglia
qualcosa in cui non vi sentivate
adeguati la stessa cosa fu vissuta da
noi medici in quel periodo perché per
l'emergenza che era in corso fumo tutti
richiamati nei reparti clinici gli ho
detto che però io sono un patologo
faccio un lavoro molto diverso in quel
momento
chiaramente il mio senso di
inadeguatezza si mischiava anche alla
paura di dover affrontare una malattia
che in quel momento
marzo2020 è pressoché sconosciuta nei
suoi dettagli
questo racconto con cui puoi seguirete
il mio ingresso in queste tre porte Vi
porterà a vedere quella realtà in una
maniera diversa
La prima porta che ho dovuto affrontare
e quella di un reparto covid-19
turno serale ore 20
ho molta paura e non so esattamente cosa
mi aspetta
devo aprire questa porta
esce il medico del turno precedente un
rapido sguardo d'Intesa
entro e per la prima volta vedo covid-19
in realtà
non lo vedo ma lo sento
lo sento attraverso i lamenti dei
pazienti il loro respirare difficoltoso
l'azione concitata dei colleghi di tutti
quelli impegnati in reparto che ha un
aspetto totalmente diverso rispetto a
quello che ci immaginiamo è stato
stravolto ci sono delle linee che
separano le zone sporche dalle zone
pulite si respira un'aria in reale e
soprattutto si respira un senso di
oppressione e di difficoltà perché non
sapevamo bene cosa fare
Questa è stata la prima porta l'indomani
dentro di me e immaginatevi la
percezione che potresti avere avuto
dalla primo contatto con questa malattia
si sviluppa un senso di impotenza e di
sgomento anche di fronte a questa cosa
ma io avevo la seconda porta da aprire
e la porta del quartiere mortuario che a
me è più vicina è un'attività che io
svolgo
svolgo normalmente ma anche in questo
caso
immaginatevi la percezione
io non so esattamente che cosa mi
attende
la Pro è di fronte a me si vede covid-19
per una seconda volta
E questa volta
nell'aspetto peggiore la letalità della
malattia
5 10 15
20 salme sono disposte all'interno dei
corridoi e dei locali normalmente
adibiti a un'attività che routinaria ma
che lì non lo era più
Io avanzo e devo letteralmente farmi
spazio tra le barelle di questi deceduti
a questo punto
dentro di me e immaginatevi questa
percezione
si crea un senso ulteriore
di impotenza e di difficoltà nel
comprendere qualcosa che assolutamente
non è chiaro soprattutto inizia dentro
di me un percorso differente perché io
solo un patologo per cui il mio lavoro è
cercare di capire queste malattie
andando a studiare gli effetti sugli
organi
in quel momento io ero realmente solo
anche all'interno della comunità
scientifica
le linee guida internazionali
avevano indicato una alta pericolosità
nell'eseguire le autopsie e questo
concetto era stato recepito anche dal
nostro Ministero della Salute Istituto
Superiore di Sanità alle società
scientifiche
giustamente Perché l'attività autoptica
è considerata l'attività più pericolosa
in medicina
ma il motivo di fondo che spingeva
questo tipo di approccio era che si
riteneva che fossero inutili perché
questi soggetti anche deceduti
decidevano per saske92 la clinica era
nota ma in questo approccio c'è un
errore di fondo perché in quel momento
noi non sapevamo nulla sugli effetti
negli organi indotti dal virus
pochi report dalla Cina ma in realtà
nulla e in più questa specie di
scafandro da non superare da non
eseguire autopsia
in quel momento
io ho deciso
faccio l'autopsia
siamo in grado di farlo e affronto la
terza porta del mio percorso
qui dovete immaginare qualcosa di molto
diverso una porta un po' particolare
siete in uno stanzino piccolo vi
liberate completamente dei vostri abiti
e vi cambiate secondo uno schema preciso
tuta per calzare doppi guanti visiera vi
siete lavati completamente e avete di
fronte a voi
la porta che permette di accedere alla
sala settoria
Seguitemi perché adesso
entriamo in covid-19
questa porta ha un apertura a pedale
Perché non bisogna assolutamente avere
nessun contatto con nessuna parte della
stanza io controllo il mio pedale
Apri un secondo si chiude in quel
momento
io ho avuto la percezione di essere
realmente solo con la malattia
sono addestrato so cosa devo fare ma in
quel momento Provate a immaginare con me
di trovarvi di fronte a una situazione
in cui realtà vi sentite inadeguato
c'è un silenzio completo io sono
completamente isolato perché posso
comunicare con l'esterno solo con un
interfono per motivi di sicurezza
Quindi avverto il mio respiro
che diventa anche affannoso e mia mi
devo controllare perché inizio la mia
attività
controllo nella stanza che ci sia tutto
in ordine tutti gli strumenti tutti i
materiali per fare i prelievi inizio
io farò questa cosa aprirò questa porta
più volte e inizierò poi quello che è il
mio lavoro cioè fare l'anatomopatologo
Ho raccolto i rapporto raccolto le
informazioni
Ma questo punto sono io il microscopio e
i miei prelievi e inizio a vedere la
malattia in un modo completamente
diverso
è una malattia virale lo sappiamo ma non
mi aspettavo di vedere questo sugli
organi
cuore
polmoni
encefalo rene tutti gli organi
presentano dei fenomeni che noi
chiamiamo lì trombosi cioè occlusione di
vasi grandi piccoli e medi in un modo
inaspettato diffuso Aggressivo e letale
questa cosa non l'aveva ancora vista
nessuno in quel momento
ed ecco perché in realtà
questura.di tre porte divento racconto
con una quarta porta che non avrei mai
immaginato e la porta che regola
l'accesso alla nostra sala riunioni dove
io mi ricordo bene quel giorno sono
andato comunicare questi primi risultati
ai medici che erano in trincea in prima
linea contro covid-19 anestesisti
rianimatori cardiologi pneumologi Ma
come vi ho detto tutto l'ospedale era
coinvolto e in quel momento io ho capito
che la possibilità di comunicare le
proprie idee può realmente cambiare le
sorti in questo caso di una malattia ho
iniziato a mostrare le immagini a
discutere dei miei prelievi e
immediatamente si è creato un
interazione con i miei colleghi
incredibile perché loro stavano già
empiricamente facendo qualcosa in quella
direzione
devono intuito anche loro che il
fenomeni vascolari fossero alla base di
molte situazioni ma in quel momento la
terapia antiaggregante la profilassi nei
confronti dei fenomeni trombotici l'uso
del cortisone non erano addirittura
consigliati in quel momento interagendo
tra le mie osservazioni e la loro
attività abbiamo capito che la malattia
poteva essere affrontati in maniera
diversa perché era una malattia diversa
rispetto Come si immaginava fino a quel
momento
ma la cosa incredibile è che non si
fermò lì ci fu un applauso che il
ricordo più bello di quei momenti perché
fu spontaneo e di grossa condivisione Ma
ripeto da quel momento nel giro di poche
ore fumo in grado di diffondere in tutto
il mondo addirittura le immagini
che avevamo raccolto il papa Giovanni
II abbiamo diffuso in tutto il mondo e
l'indomani è iniziato un contatto
incredibile coi principali ospedali che
in quel momento erano implicati nella
lotta contro covid-19
in pratica abbiamo iniziato a combattere
il virus con le sue stesse armi la
diffusione e il contagio Ma noi
l'abbiamo fatto col contagio delle idee
avendo aperto quelle porte Noi siamo
entrati in una realtà che
tecnologicamente ci permette già adesso
di comunicare con tutto il mondo per cui
ognuno di noi in realtà alla possibilità
di fare qualcosa di importante per tutti
di cambiare il modo con cui noi viviamo
quello che io ho imparato e che ognuno
di noi ha una porta là fuori da aprire
apritela
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono ancora microfonato
sono molto commosso ovviamente ma questo
è un tributo a tutti quelli che stanno
lottando ancora con covid-19 perché quel
l'idea che è nata Allora è ancora adesso
la base di tanti studi Grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]